it's Albert arterias
he doesn't need a long introduction
because we know very well his famous
breakthrough results and today he's
going to talk about consistency of
annexed not contained in people in
strong theories thank you thank you all
for coming and thanks for your to the
organizers for the opportunity to speak
here so I'm going to talk about this
thing which is join work with sambas at
UC San Diego and Maurice Miller now
professor at University of Passau
okay so let me start I can already State
the theorem so this is the strong Theory
v02 and this is the theorem next is not
in P poly this is true in a model of
physical tools so the goal of the talk
is to explain all the components in this
theorem in particular I'll explain what
these quotes are and why you shouldn't
worry about them
I'll explain what the theory is and what
does it mean to the model of
what is the significance of this
all right so this is the theorem so
let's get started there is this uh big
open problem which is proving circuit
lower bounds
and we've been stuck on complexity
theory has been stuck on this problem
for since the very beginning
so we want to prove that there is some
explicit problem a which is not solvable
with polynomial size Boolean circuits in
other words a is not in P slash poly p
slash poly stands for
polynomial time with the polynomial
advice which is the same as polynomial
size circuits
now ideally you would like this problem
to be of lowest possible complexity and
for example if it were in NP that would
be fantastic as you would show that sat
is not in pinslash poly because that is
a anti-complete
so that's the ideal situation where we
prove that NP is not in ph.4
so there are several approaches that
people have taken up to this and here
are two approaches
one approach is to enlarge NP so we take
larger complexity class so for example
maybe if we cannot show that NP is not
in peace rash probably maybe we can show
that this page is not increase fully
you cannot do that then maybe X maybe
next non deterministic exponential time
or maybe non-deterministration takes
Financial time with an empirical and in
fact for this one we do know that
there's a problem here that doesn't have
polynomial size circuits for now
what about next that's the current state
of the Arts
there's also a class in the middle that
also doesn't have two polish circuits
but next is is the current uh challenge
now the other approach is instead of
enlarging the complexity classes to
shrink the size of the the family of
circuits so for example we could
consider small depth circuits
constant depth or monotone circuits
where we don't allow negations or maybe
we restrict the circuits to be symmetric
this is what we do in descriptive
complexity for example and for these
models we have been able to show that NP
is not in this restricted classes or
polynomial size circuits
these are two approaches that people
have been taking and there's another one
which is the one from this talk which
was suggested by cook and cryachek back
in 2007 which is to prove that the
statement that you want and
the ideal statement a formalization of
it
is consistent with a first order Theory
this theory is a theory where you can
formalize mathematics and this is a the
quote just formalization of the
statement so
I will explain a bit more why is this an
approach towards trying to prove that NP
is not in business quality
so here is the consistency approach a
bit more detailed so we have two steps
the first one is to formalize the
statement that a is not in it doesn't
have polynomial size circuits and these
are the quotes in in this statement you
need to formalize this as a first order
logic statement and that's why we put
the quotes because it's not the
statement
there are several ways of formalizing
things so you should be able to argue
that one formalization is faithful and
we'll get to that
now the second step is then to prove
that this formalization is consistent
with your favorite Theory the stronger
the better
and these are the three equivalent
statements it's the same to say that uh
first order statement is consistent with
the theory
which formally means that if you add the
statement to the theory then you cannot
derive a contradiction that's what it
means to be consistent
and by the completeness theorem this is
equivalent to the statement being true
in some model of the theory
and yet another way to rephrase it is if
you take the negation of the statements
this just stands for the negation but
not
then you want to show that it's
unprovable in the theory the negation is
unprovable that's the same as the
statement being consistent
okay so these are equivalent statements
and that for whatever you prove one of
the three you get your results
now this login here and that's why it's
in the box is that the stronger the
theory
or would you prove this consistency the
stronger the evidence for the fact that
a is not in P slash poly and this is so
much so that if the theory happens to be
the theory of true arithmetic that is
all first order statements of arithmetic
and your formalization is the first
order of formalization then in fact the
consistency with respect to the true
theory is the truth of the statement
so okay so that ideally you would like
to have the true theory of uh of of
natural numbers but maybe that's not
possible so we need to look at a smaller
theories the stronger the better
all right so a series of arithmetic this
is what uh what arithmetic is about
we have piano arithmetic down here this
is not a bounded arithmetic it's just
piano arithmetic when you have first
order actions and induction for all
formulas
and at the other end we have the PV
Theory which is the theory for
polynomial time reasoning that cook
introduced back in the 1970s
and then there are two hierarchies here
this is the bus hierarchy as it's called
or you have S12 T12 s22 t22 and so on
and these are theories within the theory
P2 which stands for reasoning within the
polynomial time hierarchy
and some also introduced in the same in
the thesis uh he introduced also as a
second order Theory or as now we call it
a set sort Theory two-sorted Theory
where we have not only natural numbers
but you only have sets of numbers so
we'll get to that so this Theory
corresponds to reasoning
um with exponential time machines
exponential template
now the theory we are working with it is
the first level of the second order here
second uh yeah so this is exactly D2
it's the same as T2 but where we are
second order objects that we can Define
with bounded formulas we'll get to the
definition
all right so with squarely in the middle
of this hierarchy using this picture
now I want to argue that this is a
pretty strong Theory from the point of
view of complexity Theory
and the reason is that this polynomial
time region in theories are already
quite strong when it comes to
formalizing complexity Theory so let me
at least
uh
here's a list of alpha list one and two
slides the list of theorems that can be
formalized in within the first levels of
the P2 the P2 hierarchy the first levels
means S12 p12 and so on
for example uh this is already implicit
in in Cook's paper or in some species
you could live in theorem that satis NP
complete can be formalized in S12
theorem that says that event P has
polynomial size circuits then the
hierarchy collapses to the second level
that's also formalizable in S12
studied the circuit law Advanced
probability in bounded arithmetic and he
realized that the husted switching level
he realized no he prediscovered the
proof of the hazard switch gamma because
of his interests demanded arithmetic and
that is formalizable in the second level
uh or the third level of the hierarchy
and this is actually this formalization
was very influential later in perplex
the period so this proof exactly
it's a good byproduct of formalizing
complexity theory in boundary arithmetic
and then there is this more modern work
of data back where he proved key
formalized concepts of Randomness like
BP people bonded that are probabilistic
polynomial time he showed that other
match theorem holds in in his theory
which is low in the levels of the t2
hierarchy he also showed that grabbing
test for example it's a probabilistic
test for primality
and in particular primality of my
primary using page so the theories here
can prove that certain problems can be
solved by polynomial size circuits
that's important for us because we want
to put lower bounds against polynomial
size circuits so the theory is strong to
prove some upper bounds that's good
strong Theory
BPP is in second level graph
isomorphisms in co-am am is artwork
modeling AIDS
and the hierarchy of artwork modeling
games collapses
and now Lee and cook prove that the
bipartisan bipartisan perfect matching
problem being in the second level of the
NC hierarchy randomized is also
formalizable in this Theory
the PCP CRM one of the deepest theorem
of complexity Theory
is formalizable in National Pool which
is
in the lower bounds for circuits but it
is not in ac0 this one realized I
corrected long ago and then click is not
doesn't have monotone circuits this was
done by pink and mirror
okay so this is T2 it's a very strong
Theory from the point of view of
complexity Theory
and then what what we want to reason
about the exponential size objects like
exponential time computations so in v0
we can do that in D2 We cannot talk
about exponential size objects while in
v0 we can and for example we can do very
basic things like formalizing piece
based computations exponential time
computations and next computations and
we can show this sequence of equivalent
of inclusions which is very natural of
course
this I say follow from our work because
we worked out the details to check for
example that the bounded halting problem
for non-deterministic Turing machines is
next complete the boundary quality
problem is even a machine an input and a
number does it have a halting
competition
of that length that number yes where
does qbf being b space card fit
qbfp space hard
we didn't do that but it would I would
guess it would follow from this
there was mass impression I was just
curious about is there any like uh
famous complexities of that doesn't
follow in the best doesn't fall into war
it's not known to fall into two and
still if it doesn't deal with
exponential time competition yes
doesn't deal with uh
the theory so do you have a
characterization uh in terms of two
sorted theories just to understand T2
you have TV you have
I mean what is T2 precise
ah
it's a two-sorted theory
well that's uh what they call v0
right uh
are we there's no v01 right there is
v0 is ac0 is in V1 is p polyrhyism
D2 is not this is zero reasoning scale
down
[Music]
and this step to second order theories
or two sort of theories is necessary in
order to speak about exponential size
objects and it's well behaved in the
sense that you can do certain things at
least you can formalize computations
by the way you can prove Carly 30
minutes for this page and extra as well
okay so for example this the
formalization of bounded halting being
next complete is that there is a next
machine an explicit next machine and uh
some I mean the normal one the one you
would think m0 such as v02 proves about
it that it correctly decides about not
halting problem and moreover it also
proves that it's next complete
okay so so back to the open problem and
now it's not surprising because such a
strengths of the theorist that this is
an open problem
um the formalization which I haven't
told you yet the formalization of this
statement is it consistent with S12 this
apparently this is not known the big
open
and so let me remind you that the answer
is yes for us for unconditionally to the
hierarchy of collapsing and that's
because of car Lipton theorem right
because if Carlton if if the hierarchy
does not collapse the NP is not in
pislash poly is true and therefore it's
consistent with S12 and with any proof
here
Theory
you can even get it slightly below if
you assume that pH is not in gpp or to
the NP which is a bit low that's what an
average calculator
so conditionally we know it's true
the position though is not is not so
great in from our perspective and so
people have tried to get uh better
assumptions
weaker assumptions for example we can
try to check this paper of 2007 with the
witnessing method they proved that you
if you want to get a model of S12
well this is true it suffices to assume
this product that this doesn't collapse
here that is slightly less assumption
assumption is NP to the NP so this is
slightly less look what is the number of
queries to an emperor
that's enough to get your model
out in the same paper they showed that
if you want to go to the next level of
the hierarchy as 2-2 in the hierarchy of
T2
then you need to assume that the NP is
knocking P to the NP
but now you see that this you cannot go
I mean if if each time you go one level
of the hierarchy you're increasing this
class then you're not getting so much
Insight because we already know that if
pH is not in NP to the NP then of course
it's consistent because it's true
so this is not gaining us so this this
approach will not lead us to v0 right
be zero two
oh this is the witnessing method so let
me say two words on this so what's the
idea here
well the idea is to prove this you say
Okay assume assume it is not true within
a model in any model of a student
and what happens is that you have NP
collapses to people improvably in this
Theory and then you get some witnessing
that you can construct the circuit not
only NP is in not only status in
business poly but you can construct the
circuit and then get your collapse and
the the weaker the theory
the stronger this these algorithm is to
construct the circuit and therefore the
stronger the collapse
that's the idea of the witnessing method
now there's another set of previous
results which is with respect to fixed
size lower bounds so for every fixed
constant C
lay chicken and Oliveira showed that
NP is not does not have separates of
size n to the C is true in a model of
S12 and this is unconditional now we
have a fixed
circuit lower bound
and if you want to go a bit higher in
the hierarchy then you don't manage to
get NP you get P to the NP not having
the circuits
and now again ah and then there's this
work of carmosino cabinets
who showed that uh if you can go a
little bit higher and then you can set p
p to the NP
it should be not that this is a refined
witnessing method and it should be noted
that by Canon's theorem this is too
unconditional so NP to the NP doesn't
have
into the sea circuits so again if you
want to go higher in the hierarchy
because it looks like the higher you go
the bigger they make this class you
won't get much of an Insight because
this will know one condition
all right so this is back to our theorem
then so now we can put it in our
perspective so why is this a
why are we interested in this it's
conceptually important it's not
technically difficult let me explain why
so
so we claim that we can do that and so
here are some remarks about it so first
we don't do it for NP which is the wall
we and we don't do it for lower levels
of the hierarchy we do it for next well
that's life
our plus is that we do it for page poly
not for fixed mounts uh polynomial bonds
and we do it for this very strong Theory
which is
after all the levels of the hierarchy
so this strong Theory remember
formalizes many upper bounds for example
primality does have polynomial size
circuits
while we show that next doesn't have
foreign
can do things
and the other uh the other plus the big
plus is that it's unconditioning
so the the the message here is that we
get this sort of consistency is
making this as
a level of the where we are now in the
boundary of knowledge
but for a very strong Theory and
unconditionally
all right so let me now explain a bit
what how the theory is so how much time
you have
so this is a two-sorted language
foreign
language of first order language but too
short have two shorts one for numbers
and one for sets you have the basic
arithmetic successors addition
multiplication the sharp function or the
smash function which gives you
polynomial growth rate
in the division and length this is the
logarithm or the length of the number in
binary
the smash computer
what does it compute it's a
two to the length of x times the length
of Y in the exponent particular the
length of that number is the length of x
times the length of Y so you get
polynomial growth rate
well here it's linear growth rate right
the length of this is the length of X
plus the length of Y while here the
length of this is the length of x times
the length of one that's
it now in the language we also add all
PV symbols what are PV symbols this is a
function symbol for each polynomial time
clock levels
this is a synthetic object have a
polynomial time algorithm you add one
symbol for it
so for example you can have a symbol
that's called Euclid gcd and I put here
the algorithm itself because it's not
the function that we're adding what
we're adding is the algorithm okay
well it could be another way to compute
gcds while Computing here is a function
for this algorithm
so yeah symbol for this algorithm
primality primality has a polynomial
time algorithm
jks and you put a symbol for it
other thing is whether you can prove it
correct or not but the symbol exists
there okay
binary search I put this example here
because we also allow Oracle
computations as a as a tool we're not
hiding things in the Oracle okay and
just putting it as a tool so this would
say whether X belongs to the ordered set
y between L and r
it's a set the disorder to assume it's
ordered and the binary search algorithm
finds it in polynomials
how do you do this
which functions here polynomial term
algorithm so you may take twinning
machines and
that's your symbols yeah
it's more Concrete in the waves and with
copper definition
which gives you clock measures
now qualifier this is the first of the
theory so we have two types of
quantifiers because it's too short that
yeah you can quantify over numbers X or
Y and for this X or for all y you can
quantify over sets uh
second short and this will denote what
exists too and for two because it's the
second shot
these are they represent sets but they
are really objects of your first order
objects of your models
and then we have a membership relation
which is just a binary relation which
says that this object that supposedly
represents a set from HDM and X
all right and now we need to do some
actions so the basic actions fixing the
basic arithmetic like recursive
definitions of plus and times
cobham's definitions for the PV symbols
that's the way you define polynomial
time
machines
which was saying that for example the
recurrence that this guy has right so X
is in here if it is either in the left
side or on the right side
depending on whether it's bigger or
smaller than the middle element so
that's an equation
and you have it as one accent
and then boundaries and the
extensionality this is some basic uh
actions to say that the the objects that
represent sets are bounded
exceptionality says that every object
that represents a set is determined by
elements
these are Technical and then we have
induction and comprehension these are
the important ones induction says you
have a class of formulas and then for
every formula in this class like five in
five
in the ad induction if it's true at zero
and whenever it's towards that it's two
and Z plus one managed to objects and
this it's a bounded quantifier you're
doing this overall language
and then comprehension is the one that
adds this set objects it says that
primary formula in the class there is an
object of second type
that contains precisely the elements
that Satisfied by this is called
comprehension or Phi comprehension
comprehension with respect to formulas
inside
and now we have everything to define the
theory v02
it's precisely this Theory where we take
for Phi both induction and comprehension
is the sigma 1b0 formulas and these are
the
bounded formulas or have bounded
quantifiers of the first type
your numbers and you have zero set
quantifiers you don't have set
quantifiers
obviously you don't have quantifiers of
the second time that's what this zero
stands for so these are bounded formulas
of the number sort
you have all of them or any number of
alternations question
these are not sharply bounded
cool
this no no they are bounded in a normal
thing because that's that's what the one
is oh and the second thought
are they supposed to be finite yes the
interstellar model you're supposed to be
fine
it says that every y has enough
disease
well that means that they are bundled by
a term
[Music]
yes 500 qualifiers yes
of the first thought yes there are no
terms of the Second Source or terms of
the first one these are contagious
the same here parameters
bounded meaning that it represents a
finite set
and the action is literally for for
every y or the second type there is a z
of the first time so that every element
in y is
okay so the models is what we expect in
the standard model
standard model we have domain for the
number sort of domain for the set sort
this is supposed to be natural numbers
this is supposed to be finite subsets of
the lateral numbers
and then interpretation of the PV
symbols in the standard model they are
they are supposed to be the right
functions and so type one functions
those that don't have oracles and those
that have oracles and the oracles are
finite sets because
we only access polynomially long
like one type two functions and then you
have a standard interpretation this you
can assume that the interpret that these
guys are actually sets in any model
because of extensionality
okay so these are the models
and now we come to the formalization of
of the statement and finally we get into
those ports
let's fix the standard next complete
problem and I we chose to do the bounded
housing problem but it would have been
other problems
we could have chosen qvf but we chose
Turing machines
so one with halting problem for next
and let's fix the
standard machine for this problem m0
that's the standard machine that defines
explicitly this product
now the following are equivalent of
course because it's the next complete
you don't have polynomial size socket
the next piece but only if k0 doesn't
have polynomial size circuits
and now we want to formalize this as a
it's not going to be a single statement
it's going to be a family of statements
so this statement says that it's not the
case that k0 has a circuit of size n to
the C
okay it doesn't have that's why there is
a negation it doesn't have circuits of
size and tools
that's for mostly
now this formula how is it formalized
formally so here it is
so Alpha C says that there is a circuit
of size n to the C
for fixed c 25 a fixed standard number
so you're saying for every number n
which is not big this is a definable set
of numbers that are lengths of other
numbers so for every number
length there is a circuit of description
size n to the C this is a number
that is at most two to the end to the C
so the number of which is n to the C the
description length of C it does a
circuit
the probability length there is a
circuit of that polynomial size so that
for every input of length n
if the circuit evaluates to one
this is a PV function which is the
circuit value problem we're evaluating
the circuit C on x
then there is an accepting computation
of m0
all right and zero is the machine for k0
and if the circuit the value which the
zero then every Y is not an accepting
probability
straightforward formalization okay so
when you say to the end you mean that
for all n if there's an M such that so
this one yes
other ways you could say for all capital
n and then replace every other line by
length of capital n
and
disappear because it goes up to the way
we think yeah it's not the real time
with your language
because this is
so this is the sharp of uh obviously one
or two and the length event the length
all right so I know there's been a
tutorial on
arithmetic
but this was the first talk on bounded
arithmetic of this Workshop so I hope I
didn't bore you too much
yes
you say a little bit about why they
uh
for uh the ones that are too sorted they
should be performed okay this is because
it's a financial time computation and
the length
of the ebook
um
so what is this the size of this as a
number if you wanted to do this as an
already exponential basis
thank you
m0 so how do you for instance uh
formulate this accepting computation of
m0 this is a fixed some fixed number in
our stream yes and do you have to encode
it or you just say it exists
[Music]
and this is said by it right
we just says that every computation
expected one
foreign
we have a notion of alpha with a machine
m
and then instead of m0 we have one alpha
for MBM
but we want to I want you to notice to
prove the the prior complexity of this
formula
so these are first order type amplifiers
it's also important
small this is important for example for
the witnessing method
but from the central point of view if
you think of it this is existential this
is universal so it's a Boolean
combination of what's compiling 1v1
followers
and this is the negation by one week
back to that
because now we want to get a better
formalization and that's just to make
sure that it's um even more meaningful
result
so you have this further
characterization of next not Invisalign
it's that not only k0 is not visuals
poly but also it doesn't have polynomial
size witness circuits
it's based on the easy witness Lemma
wellerson
and what this means is that not only
um
so what would it mean to have witness
circuits it would mean that
Whenever there is an accepting
computation of this next machine there
is actually a circuit that produces this
computation that's a small weakness and
the circuit is polynomial science
so if you assume next piece in people
then not only you have a polynomial size
circuits that decide the next complete
problem but also you have polynomial
size circuits that produce weaknesses
in description of these groups this is
and that's useful because now
I can formalize it with a beta formula
again this is saying that it doesn't
have witness circuits that's why there
is a negation so the statement that says
that it does have with the circuits is
this one
it's the same structure for every length
there is a circuit of description length
n to the C and a second Circuit of
description length into the C which is
the circuit that produces the weaknesses
so that for all input lengths I'm sorry
for all inputs of that length
if C says yes then D produces a witness
as an acceptable computation
and if C says no Then There is no
accepting computation whatsoever
is
so yeah so now we got rid of this
existential from the fireflies
so when I Inspire one one because
there's only this guy one one there is
no existential quantifier here it became
a first order quantifier
which is thanks to Louisiana's Lemma is
faithful formalization and this is
better Quantified complexity
and this is important because now
this statement is not stating the
existence of potentially large objects
I mean these theories cannot reason very
much about exponentially large objects
let alone construct exponentially
electrons they cannot the theories
cannot construct exponentially with our
thoughts this formula is not claiming
the existence of such objects just doing
the opposite
yes yes but the 45 complexity is better
it's only one side of the two I mean the
existence and non-existence now it's
only about non-existence of large
objects
before it was about existence and
non-existence
okay and then as uh was asking uh
foreign
but we don't know whether Alpha the
price
so it's the fan I was wondering if you
can say something about why it's hard to
prove it easy oh yeah yeah I could say
that at the end but for one thing just
to advance it uses interactive groups
is formalizable
for next because nip is formalized
and then there is also diagonalization
against the low
advice
machines
just a lot of work or is this a
technical I think it might be a
technical this year not technical
difficult thing but I'm not sure
not only a lot of workers I think you're
smart
okay so back to the material formally
in terms of things
it's more important there's no segment
of sightseeing for anything
and that's how that's what we call but
these are the ports
what is that this is a theory it's a
bunch of followers and one for
everything well all these foreign
minutes
so what do we use here and again I want
to say that this is a conceptual
right there it's because most of the
things have already been done we had to
do a lot of work to formalize
computations
but other than that
it's using one key thing and we're
exposing that so let me tell you what
so four steps Step Zero The Stream
otherwise that things assume
right
and therefore for every model there
exists the scene where m
things the model thinks that next has
circuits of size entries
other model where the patient for
principle fails
and this is the big thing that we use
these things exist
and the fairness that is payable
principle there's an objective Mark
between an exponentially long
domain which is an element of n so it
has length of a bit so the size of the
domain is exponentially along in its
length
so generation the big map that our
polynomial machines are not going to be
able to
explore
some things
and then we interpret this as a
and again this is going to be an
exponentary long guess because like I
said earlier
so it guesses and verifies this and we
need to make sure that these gas are
verified verification is groupable in v0
meaning the machine face protagonists
so the conclusion is that this machine
is equivalent to the negation
limitations
in a second
and then we use the assumption that this
happens
weaknesses to argue
about the data contribution in fact use
the Assumption to get the contribution
because some search maps cannot be
okay so let's go back to Step One Step
Zero was the assumption
assume otherwise so step one is
the Dual theory about full of complexity
it appeared yesterday
to say about it so it says the division
for principle the propositional and
calling of it does not have that blue uh
Pizza
now this gives a model where the
original paints so so the map
so it is one to one uh
[Music]
more strongly you look at the proof what
it does is
for the visual principle fails that they
but otherwise induction
and if it holds Z then it also points at
Z plus one for element zero eight or
eight
how can this be which this model doesn't
satisfy induction
and that's true it doesn't satisfy
induction for this kind of formulas this
formula is
so it doesn't have induction for this it
has induction for bounded formula not
for second time
which is
now step two we get this machine so we
start with this model where the visual
for principle fails and now if you think
of a as an input for a machine
and you think of one is a guess of an X
machine
and then improve Lema that these
activities can't work so for it because
not only for not only for the field but
for any specific signals
machine was collected explicitly
and the function f so that v02 improves
the equivalence between
acceptance of the machine
and now this was an arbitrary machine
but we can translate it to a zero value
reduction because it's provably and next
project
so b0
knows that the negation of the position
opens equivalent to uh
section of our next complete
this is
now step three we use the Assumption to
get the contradiction right now from the
previous Lemma we have the
implementation application for principle
which is equivalent to the acceptance
competition of this next problem sorry
my assumption
what we know we know that we have
problems such as weaknesses or in
circuits
so I mean circuits in particular so
there is a circuit for
instance of that length is equivalent to
the negation of the vision because we
have a machine I mean the m0 machine and
beta0 says that this is equivalent
circuit
I recall PHP is inductive
feels a day
or because we have an equivalence we
take the C from the model
takes PHP by the negation of the circuit
but now not C is inductive
but C whole today
and now this is a violation of induction
for PV functions because this is a
circuit
circuit is evaluable
so this also gets upon the fire free
induction of obviously
so that's it oh this light actually
equivalent to a computation of a machine
The Beatles give us circuits we can
replace PHP by circuits we'll get
contradiction to quantify for induction
so conceptually this is all that there
is the difficulty is improving the
yes
and of course we're using the Dual
theorem
can you explain uh how come in this
strong theories that do prove digital
principle
themselves very very weak theories
already proof video please now I don't
understand
large objects
uh
foreign
cannot count
so Sharpie is beyond foreign
so so it's not about the pigeon
principle if it's just because of the
numbers are big it's not it's not about
the original principle it's just it's
not the it's not the use of the jewel
theorem I'm just trying to understand
the theory
there's some different scaling
well scaling is the correct one because
it says that
my opinion I think that the
time competitions
that's exactly what you want to show
what your n next is not completely
and what is the hard computation that
you don't find is the one that takes and
verifies the existence of one to one
groups
that you could also do if it's taken
over with any other function
it could work for anyone where you can
show this exactly condition
PHP has this commission and for example
other
first of all there are not so many
examples for positive trigger
but you should be able to put this into
zero
learning how to find
so
let me wrap up so in discussion two
discussions one of the problems so
improve uh you put this next
model so might it be that also
so it's independent
but it could be but then we have this
magnification theorem using this results
if it were improvable meaning that not
the people you were not provable in v02
then it would not be provable with V1 so
you have this very big gap because it's
big because in fact this can be much
lower so it's a nice one
so this is important because Raj would
have had this program to show that
circuit lower bounds are not provable in
six years and this would settle it
because it is conceivable that this is
actually
number one track not probable in this
Theory
maybe the magnification to say that this
is hard
application second discussion is that if
you tune the parameters and you exploit
all the power of the given theorem and
you can get down from next come from
Beverly
any number of books
so these almost set up the MP3
and it's not healthy okay
and this just follows from tuning the
parameters in material theorem
initialize though not I said just it
relies on that but it also in the lives
in Mario Williams this is witness Lemma
for uh not for next but for all classes
times
foreign
[Music]
expressions
or Urban problems
so can we put the easy business
and now it's very well motivated
question right
so sometimes people prove
yeah
so
maybe first we should ask this kind of
providing equals few space or MIT equals
next
up here uses algebra
can be zero two Ah that's an interesting
one it can prove primarilities in P in
btp and therefore in the poly polynomial
identity testing
if you do the usual proofs you end up
expanding polynomials
because you have this arithmetic circuit
and you expand it into a polynomial with
the sum of polynomials then you have an
exponential size object v02 might be the
Right theory for this
V12 my video
two maybe
two
the real world can we prove it invisible
it's already formalized because the next
machines you can know for the nautical
to the next machine
um yeah we exploited the lower one for
PHP so let's throw PHP in can we still
show that next result
it's like Rubble where the
relatively or subscription
q6 uh yeah and we get next so next we're
going to get it West
and b space
this is free to work so I'll stop here
thank you
more questions
just uh about the justification so you
say that there is a model that in which
the odd the fundamental hard question is
true
right but it doesn't it why is this a
justification that it is possible but
also there is a model that is untrue
well the stronger the theory the more
politics right
do you know if you have a theory and you
prove there is a model that it's it
holds in this there is a model of this
strong Theory such that Phi is true it
doesn't mean that notify is also doesn't
have a model in this trunk Theory
sure for four weeks years you could have
both ways but suppose the theory is the
true theory
it's consistent
and it's true
no but true theory of arithmetic is not
axiomatized but that's why I say that
the stronger the theory the closer you
get to truth so if you prove
consistently with I think
you're getting quite close the Internet
it's more evidence of Truth than Global
code
the proof that this these circuits work
will be very hard because
um
it's a philosophical questions
sometimes but it's also quite
incompatible and orthogonal to the other
approaches where you'll receive the kind
of circuits
for example here what we're doing is
in some sense we are
a dual theorem which is what it's doing
is constructing and accepting
computation
for a machine that should project
from the assumption that the customer
sensor
so it's a it's a way to construct a
non-existent objects
and it's not a Miracle Construction it's
really a it's really a computation in a
machine that is m086 is a fixed machine
in the real world
you're constructing an object in a
Non-Stop model that
from the point of view of the theory
looks like a competition
so it seems that the argument in some
sense
from the probability in the period and
activities for in order to have this
short weakness surface getting some kind
of quantifier elimination so you're
getting it just for the sentence Express
induction for PHP or you can can you do
it for more General formulas can you
guess
it's just in general it's in general
because the next
approach all
a sigma one one formulas through the
next machines
please
so where has a certain place including
in this term power of theories in other
words where is it the case that if you
prove
something consistent is true
statements
it's a model we have to rename sometimes
they are doing video
you're asking how far we need to go how
far is is
the stronger the theory the more it's
convincing to us um that it's true and
like in this picture that these are two
lives above the whole T2 hierarchy uh
but I guess in like the sentence you're
proving is
I think uh consistent is a sigma one one
like it's not interpretable in T2
from my understanding unless you take a
log of everything
and the consistency does not apply to
that version right
so like what would the interview of this
implying inconsistency of something for
T2 what would the statement what does it
implied for Teacher just to run survives
like um
the question
for next we don't know any important
that's why the question for peace page
and actually is important
with most theories
I think we can formalizing them first of
all
right
but there is the motivation for the last
open problems is precise with your
questions and you get actually yeah
foreign
performance
busy why is it that the Dual theorem
corresponds to getting
why I think gives a model of using a
book
because
the soundness of
um
foreign
[Music]
on it
question uh the magnification yeah
uh or I guess I mean like NX
next one
this question that might an exercise
yeah
but it's it's with the coverage with
modifications
week
s